et moi gérard ya une question que je
voulais te poser quand même pourquoi tu
débarques toujours les émissions de télé
là tu débarques chez dechavanne là ce
soir tu es j'ai débarqué dans mon
émission qu est-ce qui c'est quoi cette
histoire c'est le deuxième fois je
voudrais pas devenir le spécialiste de
ce genre de choses dans général disons
que c'est par solidarité
la première phase t pour lorsqu'elle est
cette espèce de nazillons révisionnistes
et là ce soir c'est quoi j'ai pas
compris là ce soir c'est comme ça nous
leur humeur eu envie de numéro un qui
chez toi tu regarde la télé puis d'un
seul coup tu t'habitues prends ta
bagnole et tu viens pas de façon
systématique mais voilà c'est le
deuxième fois bon bah écoute maintenant
c'est à moi de te confessé oui ça te va
comme moi pour souligner la samba oui
qu'est-ce que tu que je te dise que
c'était spontané c'est un acte ça suffit
c'est bien sûr vu c'est une pulsion est
ce que tu es favorable divorce
oui
ce qui serait une femme avec deux trois
ans quand j'ai quitté une femme avec un
enfant qui penche dès fois a toujours
oui mais j'y pense que la vie ne lui
empêche pas de les revoir et de devoir
élever ma fille bon je me suis marié je
divorce et l'euthanasie tu serais
d'accord
dans l'absolu on dans l'absolu oui pour
avoir été confronté à deux trois cas
comme ça désespérer totalement oui
désespéré donc oui mais c'est un
problème très délicat de suicide
oui oui il n'ya pas commenter le suicide
je pensais être suicidé toi
non pas vraiment mais pour les autres ça
te fait pas peur il n'y a pas de pas de
peur à voir pour les autres je pense
qu'on est
je pense que c'est aussi une certaine
façon une certaine façon à donner un
prix à sa vie que se suicider c'est une
espèce d'ultimes pouvoir qu'on a de vie
et de mort de sa propre vie de sa propre
mort gelé ouais je repris est-ce que tu
est favorable à la peine de mort non pas
du tout je suis contre la peine de mort
et surtout n'enchaîne candidants messi
veut ta fille vous avez quelque chose à
ton enfant et tout ça je suis contre la
peine de mort même les assassins
d'enfants même pour les assassins
d'enfants et une façon un peu plus
anecdotique je pense que je ne pourrai
jamais partagé une salle idées de le pen
donc à partir du moment où il est à ce
point
pour la peine de mort même si j'étais
totalement ignorante de ce sujet même si
cela ne concerne pas je serai de
systématiquement opposés parce qu'ils
pensent le contraire
c'est c'est très clair tout ce qui s'y
est dit favorable à la légalisation des
drogues douces wii board où ça veut dire
quoi herbe chiite tout ça maintenant je
sais pas s'il est totalement l'accord
pour enfin bon
oui je pense que ça changera pas trop le
problème il ya il ya un certain nombre
d'exemples la la la land l'espagne
quelques pays comme ça ça n'a pas trop
bouleversé le paysage politique j'allais
dire le cpi tu crois en dieu
oui ça sera le moment j'essaie de vivre
ça au quotidien
c'est à dire que je ne suis pas
pratiquant je suis je suis juif au cas
où tu ne serais encore pas donc je ne
suis pas pratiquant mais plutôt que
d'attendre des fêtes qui ou pardonne ou
et s'avoue coq sgc ou au quotidien de de
comprendre d'être le mois banal et
médiocre possible et de donner un
maximum
celle là façon dont elle à moins d'y
croire tu crois au diable
bah oui une vérité une contre vérité
certainement ja oui oui l'équilibré à
ton avis quelle forme il prend le diable
aujourd'hui tout tout ce qu'on est en
train de faire est diabolique
la conception de cette émission et des
reliques
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu